Okay, Mikey, you got answers for me?
>> sure.
>> Alright.
>> Wait, should I, do need to make any assumption, or
can I make any assumptions I want about the non-blue states?
>> No. It doesn't matter. [LAUGH] Actually. [LAUGH]
>> So the answer is no.
>> Maybe it does.
>> The answer is no. But it
doesn't actually matter because Remember, it's all
very stationary and Marcovian. So the only thing that matters is where you are.
>> You're stationary Marcovian. Alright, so I think,
okay. So let's, let's do the first one, then.
>> Okay.
>> So, so this is, this is pretty cool.
So by changing the reward the way that you
did, it is now, it's not a hot beach
anymore. It's like. You know like, super awesome money beach.
>> Yes, it's like a beach made of bacon.
>> Sure. Okay. Let's think of it that way.
Although neither of us is eating bacon at the moment.
>> At the moment.
>> But. [CROSSTALK]
>> Great, because, because then our mouths
would be full and it would be very difficult to give
this lecture. Alright so, no, no, no,no, no I mean like, even.
Alright, never mind. The point is that it's awesome, and there's like
diamonds. I don't know, I just saw The Hobbit movie, and there
is a room filled entirely with treasures. And so, this is
kind of like that. And so now the question is, what should
I be doing, like I should never go to the plus 1
or the minus 1, because that ends my treasure gathering. I should
just continue to stay in states that aren't those states.
>> Okay.
>> So I would say left for the, for the top state.
>> Mm-hm. Let's say left for the bottom state.
>> This one?
>> The, yes, uh-huh.
>> Okay.
>> And the other two, I need to think about for a moment.
So I feel like I'd like to get away from the minus 1.
>> Mm-hm.
>> So, like, you know, to go up.
But then that would give me some chance of slipping, wouldn't it?
>> Mm-hm. let's see, I don't want to go to the right. I don't
want to go down. I don't want to go. I'm going to go to the left.
>> Mm-hm.
>> I'm going to bash my head against the wall, because then I get money.
>> Yeah.
>> That's weird. There's really no pain for running into the wall?
>> No. You just stay where you are.
>> Alright and for the bottom one, I feel
like it's the same kind of thing. I don't
want to go to the right or to the left,
cause then there's a probability that I'll slip and
end up ending my game. So I'm going to go down.
>> yeah. I like that. So most of these are
right, and one of them is wrong. Or, it's not
that it's wrong, it's just that's not as right as
it could be. Which one do you think that is?
>> I think they're right. But if, if
there's one that I could imagine you not being
so happy with, which is the bottom one,
There are two bottom ones. You mean this one?
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. What would I like?
>> I think
you might prefer if I bash my head against the wall.
>> No, actually, it turns out that this is
a correct answer so all four of these are correct.
But in this particular state, it actually doesn't matter which
way you go. Oh, I see. A more complete answer.
>> Yes.
>> Would be, doesn't matter.
>> Yeah.
>> And is that true of any of the other ones? No. I guess,
I guess you're right. The other ones, you have to go in the direction indicated.
>> Right. So, by the way, just like
here, it doesn't matter which direction you go in.
It's actually true for all of the other
states as well. It doesn't matter where you go
because In these three states, these are the
only states where you can accidentally, you could end
the game. And in each of them, you
can take an action that guarantees that you don't
end the game. So it really doesn't matter
about where you do it in the other states.
>> Cool.
>> Right? So that's a good argument. This makes
a lot of sense. So at the end of the
day, basically, because the reward is positive. And you're just
accumulating reward or diamonds and treasure, as you put it.
You just never want to leave, so you always want to avoid either
of these states. It doesn't matter that there's a +1 here
and a -1 here. If I can stay here forever, then
I just accumulate positive reward forever. Okay, so what's the next one?
>> So, interesting. So now, now the beach
is really, really hot. It's minus 2, so.
>> Mm-hm. I want to get off here as quickly as I can. So definitely the top
one, I would go to the right. Just try to
get, get that +1 and get out of, get outta here.
>> Yeah.
>> Alright, so then, let's think about the bottom right.
>> Okay.
>> So, in the best of all possible worlds
I go around and dump into the +1. And that
would take me again if, if I don't slip
at all one, two, three, four steps to do that
>> Mm-hm.
>> Actually wait one, two, three, three steps one
the hot sand.
>> Yup
>> And I'm getting and -2 for each of those. So that's like minus 6.
>> Mm-hm.
>> So I could get that plus 1 at the end, and that
makes it only minus 5. But I think I'd rather just get off the
beach. So I'm going to say in the bottom right to actually dive into
the pit of pain, because it can't be as bad as where I am.
>> That's exactly right.
>> So, okay, so then the, the one next
to it on the left is a little trickier.
If I go up to the plus 1, I get a minus 2 Followed by a +1 which is also -1.
>> Mm-hm.
>> So okay. I'm not so sure about that one.
>> Well remember you'll always have some
probablitly of ending up back where you started
>> Is that true? Oh because, if I. Well no,
no, that's not true if I dive straight into the
-1. Then I have 0.8 chance of going to the
-1. 0.2 of going up. To the arrow that's labeled,
0.2 going down to the blue box that's not labeled
>> Mm-hm.
>> Wait, 0.2? No, 0.1
>> Whereas if I go up, right, I might stay where I am.
And accrue -2, like, yeah I feel like I need a calculator for this.
>> Yeah, but you're, I think your intuition
is right, though. Just think about it as
How much, I mean what do you think
has the best chance of most quickly ending things?
>> Well certainly jumping
into the -1.
>> Right.
>> I think that's going to be marginally
better because there's only one chance of slippage
and delay. Where as if I take additional
step, there's two chances of slippage and delay.
>> Exactly, that's exactly the right kind of argument to make
and, and because the -2 is so big. You're you're going to, you're
just better off ending it even if you ended in pain, in
the same way that you were in the bottom right hand corner.
>> And so bottom left I would say the cleanest thing
would be to jump into the -1. So to go to the
right so that I can go up and get into the -1.
>> And what's nice about that move is that is that you either end up in the
bottom right hand corner. Or you end up
staying where you are, or you end up moving
up. But in either case, you are always
sort of, you know, you never get farther away,
right? Whereas if you try to go up,
there's a chance that you will get farther away.
>> Interesting. Is there a way to be sure about these?
>> Yeah, you just have to do the math.
>> [LAUGH]
Do we know how to do the math?
>> Yeah, you just start, you just do expectations. You
can basically just say, well what's the expected time. Since
you know what you're trying to do here is to
get to the end. You can just, you can calculate the
expected length of time it'll take you to get there.
And then just, you know, multiply by all the rewards you're
going to get in the meantime. If it helps, though, I
will tell you that for any value where the reward is
less than minus 1.6284.
>> [LAUGH]
>> This is the right thing to do.
>> [LAUGH] Okay.
>> Just so you know.
>> Alright, so you're saying you actually do know that
this is the optimum. The thing that we have here.
>> Yes, I know that this is the optimum.
>> Alright. Let me just draw out the rest of it for
you. So it's, it's I think interesting to compare this one. The bottom
right one, where you have given me negative rewards to encourage
me to end the game. With our main one up here in
the upper left. Where you have also given me some negative reward
to encourage me to end the game. If you look carefully you'll
notice that in this one, you're encouraged to end the game.
But you're really encouraged to end the game at a plus 1.
Here the reward is so strongly negative, you just need to end
the game. And so you end up with a different response, here.
Because this is, is just as quick to get to
the minus 1 and into pain as to, take this extra
step and try to get to the plus 1. And you
end up with a different response here. Here, here, and here.
>> That's really interesting.
>> Yeah, it is. And so, these changes matter. They matter a great deal.
>> So, how am I suppose to choose my rewards?
>> Carefully and with some forethought.
>> Nice.
>> But, you know,
again There's lots of ways to think about this. So the way we've been sort of
talking about MDPs is kind of the way
we've been talking about we talked in the first
part of the course. When we talked
about having teachers and learners. You can think
of your reward as sort of the teaching
signal. Sort of the teacher telling you what
you ought to do, and what you ought not to do. But another way of thinking
about this is that because the rewards define
the MDP The rewards are our domain knowledge.
>> I see.
>> So if you're going to design an MDP to
capture some world. Then you want to think carefully about how
you set the rewards in order to get the behavior that you wish.
>> That's fair. I mean, it seems a little bit like
a cop out, but I think it seems like a necessary one.
>> Yeah. I mean, there's really, I mean, again. No matter what
you do, you've gotta be able to inject domain knowledge somehow. Otherwise,
there's no learning to do. And in this case, the reward basaiclly
is telling you how important it is to get to the end.
>> Cool.
>> Okay. Alright. Let's move on.